okay here we go
[Music]
apologize
[Music]
let's all go to the merch shop
let's all go to the murder shop
let's all go to the murder shop and buy
ourselves some sway
beautiful snazzy clothing and swag to
buy at crowdershop.com
like this new signature baseball tee
or these hoodies or of course the holy
grail itself mug club let's all go to
the merch shop
buy ourselves
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
changes
[Music]
hmm
that's called a uh not a rush sip but a
purposeful sip yeah because we have a
lot to get to we have ed durr on the
show yes for people who don't know he's
the uh
the best politician in america
who spent like he raised to be fair like
five hundred dollars spent 150 and took
one of the most important uh state seats
in new jersey very cool finance
violations so of course the claws have
come out from the media we'll be talking
about uh talking about that uh for those
on a truck driver who uh just decided he
was going to run turns out he uh has
tuned into the show
that's all i'll say i don't want to be a
liability to him and
lesson from yesterday
uh
don't put an autistic person on the
stand
and screw it up like the prosecution did
in the cal written don't make them
hungry
and i say this in the friendliest way
someone who clearly is on the spectrum
yeah who might as well have uh put down
a bed of pillows for the prosecution
turned on some barry white and gone at
it slow
it's done he was awesome
so we're gonna talk about that and then
something else look
i don't say this uh just to try and
not to be divisive i've heard people say
divisive i don't like those people
uh they're wrong but a lot of people
have been talking about secession what
that means in the united and now both
sides you're talking about close to half
of both sides yeah wow think that it's a
real possibility and i want to talk
about what that looks like and who
actually gets to be america if you have
america and then you have whatever
american number two uh who gets to still
be the united states of america i think
you know where i line up on it because
uh the left uh hates america you know i
could really just say this you you you
well the the left district states don't
get to be america why not because you
kneel for the flag you created a
different flag and a different anthem
that's it done but we wouldn't have a
show so
we're talking about all of that today
before that gerald how are you i am well
sir how are you i'm okay just okay i'm
okay
joe lewis here hip checked me hard what
do you deserve in the prep room yeah he
didn't get a walk this morning i don't
blame him ran at me full pin jumped
turned his hip and took out my knee and
he did it smiling he did it smiling
powerful
he could have bitten off your arm and
you're complaining about it now check we
live by his mercy could you just imagine
if he went into an epileptic fit in here
yeah
we're nice to him for a reason i'll be
like the mayor of amnesty though listen
we do a show every night every 10 a.m
eastern and i will be damned if we stop
because of some dog
uh the show must go on dave landau is
here by the way before i introduce him
he is going to be in wichita kansas this
thursday this thursday at the caption oh
he's in naples to 19th century
and off the hook ahoy you good ahoy i'm
good how about you sir well aside from
the knee blow out from joe lewis but joe
lewis was very affectionate today he
wanted me to to pet him just so yeah
well he has a little he has a little ear
thing going on yeah and he's very
specific where he's like this here yeah
don't go anywhere do this now he also
just
he also he attacked a minority this
morning and that was what's the real
problem i kind of buried the lead on
that one token island
no i don't want to get into it because i
don't want to admit to it uh on air okay
quick trip it was a quick trip it'll be
henceforth known as the
joe lewis quick trip incident incident
yes and by the way everyone here
watching if we get bands today talking
about we never know when we will be
we're talking about the trial cal
written house the show is going on just
not on youtube it'll go on rumble or on
mug club today we have an extended
interview with uh ed der on mug club so
do consider joining up or at the very
least heading on over to rumble if we
don't tell you that there is no show
there is a show just might not be here
it's always a show we still don't know
about it we just don't know about it
okay before we get to anything else it
is you introduce quarter black yeah
nobody else oh sorry i'm sorry quarter
black i have so much to get to is it
because of the it's because i was okay
he's the one joe lewis attacked he's the
one joe lewis attacked that's all out in
the open that being said he made joe
lewis uh uh fight a shih tzu down the
block because he couldn't help himself i
thought he was a good fighter yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then he tossed it he
tossed an electric blanket over the shih
tzu in a bathtub oh well just trying to
keep it not one person lost that bet no
no
it's like even at a plus twenty five
thousand you still make the safe
keep the hair it's nice thank you i'm
jealous uh let's go to this first so
here is a new way for leftists to
explain
i don't even to explain mansplaining
[Music]
the bottom right looks like every
androgynous pixar character like the
friend like i don't know how to talk to
girls
[Music]
yeah it looks like john cryer in the
[Music]
[Music]
80s what a waste of talent
what talent they actually say can
actually sound pretty good
just idiots i wonder if they're good at
making sandwiches
i joke that bottom left throws it all up
yeah i'm gonna say
kind of rough down there yeah next thing
she'll be singing
rainy days and mondays get her down yeah
but
that pipe's gonna be real acidy yes
hey that's unsolicited advice how is
that not uh bitch-splaining yeah
like don't explain to me how to explain
the problem with mansplaining like
sometimes it is a thing like with my
wife there was a bird in the house okay
this week and i don't know if you've
ever had that mo if you ever had a bird
or a oh i have and you see it the first
time but you're not sure if you're crazy
and then you're shooting i said am i
crazy or she goes i don't know i didn't
see a bird
and then three hours later we found the
bird again yeah because it just it was
you know it kept flying into the windows
i was like this person should be in the
witness stand and
then
i had to explain to my wife how you
catch a bird she's just like oh maybe
she's like crawling up on it like this
like she's like oh oh no you have to get
a blanket you have to yeah it's like
what why are you explaining that to me
because yeah because yeah yes yes i
guess that's mansplaining can we go back
to the three hours over the weekend that
you thought that there was a
hallucination going on
you saw you said you saw a bird and
she's like i didn't sleep and then three
hours later you fight a bird yeah for
those three those three hours you were
like
what the hell what did i eat is it i had
i had a bologna sandwich i had mushroom
mushrooms ah i do that all the time
like i'll see like a fly and then i'm
like that wasn't
no and then like two hours later i'll
see it i'm like oh thank god right i
thought that was insane but maybe it was
a different fly i don't even know we
don't even know because every now and
then i slip uh i slip some shrooms in
your in your cheerios i notice it's an
old trick micro it's not relapse if you
don't do it it's nature's true
psilocybin is nature's cruelest trick i
pay people to relapse me
see this way it's not on as long as i
don't know
i always love how too they they're like
oh yeah you know how you cure drugs
ayahuasca it's like oh yeah how do you
cure drugs with more drugs or drugs
that'll make you vomit well the ones
that the doctors say you should take
that are more potent yes and by uh
doctors i mean nathan phillips
ah you get in touch with nature in your
spiritual hold on i have call waiting
it's my dentist he's a t-mobile guy okay
my question to you is look do you really
think that there's a solution here is
america going off a cliff that's
honestly the question of the day and do
you think that secession or separating
the country is a way to avoid
uh potentially what both the left and
the right have been increasingly
uh
voicing concerns regarding some kind of
violent conflict i really i think that
we need to do everything we can to avoid
that and you know what we we may be i
think there is a certain point where we
have to recognize there's a crossover
and certain people don't have the same
vision uh for the united states of
america so that's my question to you you
of course can subscribe uh to the
podcast anywhere it's not on youtube
apple android spotify all that taking
your chat later all right
i think it's really going to come down
to what we realize we're more passionate
about yeah like if we believe what we're
saying not us but like people really
believe in their stance right or if they
really would prefer just to not move
because right it's a pain yeah like yeah
exactly like me with the constitution or
quarterback with purple drink yeah it's
delicious
it is delicious
and a hoodie it's like that old
chappelle sketch but it's a sunny d and
they show the kid who's like the black
and he probably loves the purple yeah
all right so let's go i'm looking for
speaking of a purple drink uh because
it's usually filled with uh
medication uh let's talk about the
pfizer ceo this is terrifying if you
guys haven't seen this clip
the pfizer ceo albert borla
uh
bond villain by the way he just needs a
report just needs a railroad track and
natasha and he's there you'll see what i
mean uh he said that people spreading
misinformation meaning people spreading
information he doesn't like
about vaccines are quote criminals this
is very scary there is a very small part
of professionals which they circulate on
purpose misinformation so that they will
mislead
those that they have concerns
those people are criminals they're not
bad people they're criminals because
they literally cost them
millions of lives
and then should be treated as criminals
as well think about that
huh by the way who determines what is
misinformation
for companies yeah alphabet google
youtube right same company facebook
twitter you can maybe throw an apple in
there think about that for a second
they should be treated as criminals that
means everyone in this room
that means my doctor yeah that means the
doctor who told my wife who by the way
you all know the story gbs right i had
to leave a show early because she was
paralyzed from the waist down after a a
routine anesthesia was administered so
what all of them need to be because you
said there's no valid reason think of
how terrifying this is yeah absolutely
and by the way he just said do you know
what the global death toll from covet is
roughly at this time around five million
right right he said millions of people
have died because of this okay millions
that's at least two million right plural
so roughly 40
of the death toll is because of
quote-unquote misinformation
he just made a straw man argument
everybody's like oh my gosh it costs
freaking out of turn you're disturbing
my cat
yeah at some point did andre the giant
have uh sex with al franken's mom
because that is what that looks like
i am a monster and i run this company
i'm gonna be ceo of pfizer oh smash so
speak i have criminals in my neck
because i'm a scientist he's alive he's
waiting for the hands to come up
the final ceo is alive so
let's just look at some of pfizer's
worst crimes all references available at
laddersquad.com in the description uh in
2009 a 2.3 billion dollar with a b
finally had to pay for the biggest uh
fraudulent marketing campaign ever
they also
are the number one right in fines in
history
because 2.3 billion was enough 331
million for bribery
2012 55 million for drug and equipment
safety violation 2013 490 million for
under promotion of medical products 2013
250 million fined for unapproved
promotional medical products they did it
again they didn't learn their lessons uh
the same year that's not a typo the same
here 490 unapproved promotion hey they
said hey you have to stop approving
those medical products because that's
actually not the science he's like but i
do follow science okay i have learned by
listen he went out a revolving door came
back and like now it's 257 billion what
come on
meet me halfway
i fixed it with more crime yes well look
in all fairness the bribery charge was
trying to get out of the 2.3 billion
dollar fine so i mean it just how else
you're supposed to get out of fine new
bribe yes
you can pay it what no
pay
it's it's cheaper to bribe actually you
paid more than the fine i know i missed
i always forget to carry the lamb
mundane details that a laser and a shark
swimming pool what's it to you mind your
own business
so feed my orca
2016 784 million for a false claims act
2016 again 371 million for false claims
act 2019 another 41 million so the point
is here look and i'm not saying that
there aren't two sides to every uh two
billion dollar fine you have to pay yeah
sure but
uh
this guy's just an [ __ ] can i just be
clear about like i just i
we're at a certain point we're beholden
to these people here's something else
that he said though so everyone was
talking about the criminal comment and
they should
but there was something else and token
owen pointed this out when i was
watching the clip
they're kind of separated from each
other but it's important to note he does
this under the guise of it's a
democratic process
and then sort of feathers out into
some completely undemocratic
institutions so this tells you where his
might where this professional criminal's
mindset is what we we are seeing it is
uh
what uh democracy is all about people
should have an opinion you are not
in a situation that you can
ban people from saying what they believe
so when people are saying what they
believe they are people that believe
differently so that
it's regular that will lead to some
confusion
eventually we have processes in the
democracy the process is the fda that
will approve or not the product the
process is the cdc that will lead to a
recommendation or not okay course things
have happened so and right now we are
already rolling out
the boosters to those that they want
them and i believe that that will be
very successful oh by the way i just got
in my delorean uh 2022 they have to pay
492 million for false claims
what oh you're such a stick letter so
what is democratic about the fda and cdc
think about that
he said democratic process this is the
problem when people talk about the swamp
you often think about people you know
like the dick durbins of the world or
you think about the schumers of the
world and granted i understand that too
they're they're they're incredibly um
uh irritating but
safest word you could do the issue here
is you have so many appointed people in
positions of authority uh who've never
been elected remember the cdc was the
reason for extending the rent moratorium
uh the cdc was now all of a sudden in
charge of national security because of
the health issues right you can and all
of a sudden people who aren't elected
are in charge of all these issues so let
me give you an example yeah yeah
democratic process the fda commissioner
janet woodstock appointed by biden her
salary is 370 plus thousand dollars a
cdc director rochelle wilinski making
over 200 000 that's not including
benefits and of course who could forget
uh the niad director anthony fauci
completely unelected and he's the
highest paid federal employee with a
multi hundred thousand dollar salary so
yes this democratic process what do you
mean by that uh
atheist oligarchy yeah well and you
remember you can't question the cdc and
then you certainly can't question the
who until the cdc questions the who and
then i'm not sure what the rules are
then you can question if you want to be
criminal gulag is that way yeah wasn't
it clinton two that like kind of lacks
the drug laws in the 90s with the fda
where they didn't have to approve
medication before it went out which i
think here's the thing i think that's a
good thing yeah but but that was that
was if i'm not mistaken i think it
happened under clinton it happened in
the 90s okay but the issue there is even
then you have to prove that there's some
reason for prescribing something off
label right they're just like hey
if you have cholesterol why don't you
take riddling yeah yes
take cheese yes yes also this is
concentrated pill of ayahuasca's you in
48 hours maybe 72. no misinformation i
give it to you for uh addiction issues
for depression and rattle itch it's
multi-purpose just now while i talk to
you i lost a three million dollars in
vines yes i do not know you say did you
say
vines vines vines oh fine
not vine that's no longer people don't
like short videos
i talk long about how you shouldn't be
able to talk yes yes yes it is it's
democratic process
when i arrest you well listen you have
opinion you go to jail that's it he's
democracy
that's how it's working
yes yes you know where i come from
democracy rape you so i bring to america
for you jakov take my whole act
so i have him killed
not really seem to branson
same difference i kill his career i
haven't sit next to half titanic museum
yes
by the way we have about uh probably 2
000 people right now watching from
branson who are like i know it's a
really [ __ ]
no
it's my wife or anniversary like i do i
do enjoy yakov show yeah but no actually
no joke apparently it is a fantastic
show it's not him though it's probably
funny yeah so okay i don't want to see
half a titanic though wow that is some
boat it's
a museum and it's just half the titanic
so it's sank like this yeah it's like
they didn't scale it down
right
they just said we'll just make a half
titanic can't afford the whole thing
can't build a full titan we'll just make
it a smaller titanic like nah half is
the way to go it's one of two i think
the other one's in either i think it's
tennessee is it the other half
no it's not the other half they have two
is it that's real titanic or they just
built it it's a scale no it's not the
reason why i really just watched the
titanic
i have no idea well what's the
difference if it's made up i know that i
went to branson because my wife is all
obsessed with the titanic thing she
doesn't like the movie that much though
surprisingly uh and uh they give you
like a name someone who's actually on
the titanic at the beginning of the
museum did you ever die oh i died
were you jack it was an old lady
i was like she's definitely i don't like
she's going down she was supposed to be
in the lifeboats first but you know
people are like she's in a life
expectancy
like you've had a good run they just
shoved her off yeah
oh that you know they weren't classy
about that of course not
women's lip i just like how the band was
that yeah the band where it's like the
the only black people in the movie are
just they're still playing yeah like
we're not we're not making this the life
though
they're not gonna let us on
the film was not accurate by the way
because i continued playing classical
film is not accurate because she's
terrible woman who just let him die
she did she's like i'll never leave you
jack and before she even feels for a
pulse she's like
crack your fingers off of her not want
to explain to billy zayn about how we've
been banging this whole trip he brought
me on she's a horrible think about it
she could have sold that uh part of the
ocean whatever it is and uh her
grandkids you know could have gone to
college fed the poor in the water do you
think jack cares that you threw it in
the water he's dead
so weird a while so weird to think that
that's the same guy from django okay
let's see right here colin kaepernick we
do have a guest so we can't go too long
today but uh uh i'm having fun uh we got
but anyway colin kaepernick i was going
to go back to the russian thing and i
said
it's too easy
we've killed it like you will be
redline
some people redline district redline
your nick so
colin kaepernick just so you know we
have some exclusive info here you know
uh there's an update you guys all know
in case you had forgotten colin
kaepernick uh
i think he's
egyptian i don't know i don't care it's
immaterial so he in case you've
forgotten he did this documentary uh
very in demand documentary breakthrough
documentary for netflix here's a
refresher
before they put you on the field
teams poke
pride and examine you
searching for any defect that might
affect your performance no boundary
respected
no dignity left intact
no white guys in the nfl draft not at
all none
weird
come
at that shape there look at this
mr fiber i got your bid 30. james 30 to
you 100. these guys on steroids coming
up best one we got
all right so look uh he has some new
projects too uh yesterday kaepernick's
publishing company uh
they're promoting this new book
abolition for the people and in tiny
print it says the movement for a future
without policing in prisons oh boy so
they always put that in a timely
difference like no it's about equality
and justice and you get all like you get
soccer yeah that's what happened in
virginia soccer moms knowing suburbia
like yeah equality and justice yeah and
no prisons or police wait what
hold up exactly and here's something
else he's documented and he's a writer
and now he's an actor yeah so he has
this is this people didn't realize this
this was a documentary to go along with
kaepernick has actually uh secured the
rights and um sort of reinterpreted
the classic film you know classic
racially charged film roots and we have
an exclusive look at it
[Music]
i want to hear you say it
i want to hear you say what your signing
bonus is
i'm a good quarterback
that's what my mama said your sign in
bonus is 20 million
i want to hear you say it boy
50
50 million
if you're willing to do a contract
extension
we might be able to offer
30.
no
no
lord god
help that boy
get him a flex deal with a point on the
merchandising back end
[Music]
all right boy
i'm not promising anything
and really i shouldn't even be saying
this but the best we can do
is 35 million
and that is absolutely the best we can
offer
but i can probably get you another five
as a performance bonus
if you get us to the postseason
i want to hear you say it oh no
no
what's your sign and bonus
35
million i
say it again
say it so they all can hear
[Music]
35 million
with a 5 million performance bonus if i
take the team to postseason
hi
that's a good quarterback
yes
okay look oh that's hey everyone
watching here we took a risk so smash
that like button
smash that like button and comment to
help the algorithm uh
we're gonna need it i think i just got
canceled again yeah yeah
hey wait hold on
that was me caring
[Music]
millionaire who's talking about slavery
you don't find that funny come on you're
missing the point yeah you really are
it's absurd to even compare the two uh
really quickly by the way right now i
guess cal rittenhouse is on the stand uh
let's see what's going on really quickly
yeah yes your honor so that'll be a
choice that i'll i would that's his
mother uh mr on the right uh sir
obviously or mr um richards okay so
listen if anything happens while we are
live today we'll have a control room let
us know we'll cover this tomorrow
because we don't want to necessarily
need to be first with us we need to be
right right well the judge actually was
giving him instructions just a second
ago and he said now son you realize that
the prosecution has made your case for
you so just don't say anything you
realize that basically your testimony
you can just point and say what he said
yeah the prosecution just making sure
you understand that's actually what the
defense can do too
and then rest
acquittal so anybody yeah this whole
thing is ridiculous this is really
pretty it's kind of a waste of my time
at this point when you think they order
some cookies here yeah yeah
oh hey lunch i was thinking anyone feel
uh feeling uh feeling uh up for sherry's
berries yeah macadamia nuts too
that he pointed the gun at him i was
like case this week
yeah you know i got this early you know
i thought that this guy knew that he
could
lie
yeah
he just agreed i was like oh this is
perfect you know he could lie he could
invoke the fifth he could say uh no
hey prosecutor that was your guy
and he got pissed off the spectrum kid
you wouldn't believe how many letters
they get saying when's the defense gonna
stop calling witnesses and say they're
gonna prosecute their defense hasn't
called any witnesses
so all right let me give you a recap
here of what happened uh this week
because yesterday with the climate
change episode which is a reference
piece it's a whole two hours of
myths from 1970 to today so we missed
some stuff so um here's the thing uh
gage
crew scroots but let's just call them mr
gage bicep guy
yeah
admitted
just so you know this happened two days
ago and then yesterday was this autistic
witness i believe and i don't say that
as an insult brilliant no actually and
what they call a i don't know if it's
audiographic kind of memory there's a
term for the
audio equivalent the auditory equivalent
of a photographic right yeah you can
tell this guy has it and he wasn't being
pushed around so that was yesterday a
lot of people have missed it but let's
talk about the defining moment that
should absolutely result in the
acquittal says gage admitting that kyle
only shot when he
charged him and pointed his gun at kyle
written house
to look like right now and watch the
prosecution's reaction it looks like my
bicep being vaporized yes okay
nice
thank you for pointing your
[Music]
right correct it wasn't until you
pointed your gun at him watch the
prosecution's reaction
with your gun now your hands down
pointed at him
that he fired right
correct
you believe that he was
but you had mentioned that you believed
he was re-racking his gun look at the
prosecution
is in his
and you can see actually at one point he
goes like this yeah he's like oh okay
but he goes oh look this and by the way
here's the thing prosecution even if you
know your case is screwed like even if
you feel like this
you don't do it even if a fighter loses
a decision you you know throw their
hands up try and sway the judges
you got to look confident out there like
i won that everyone knows you didn't but
maybe one judge is like oh he seems to
believe it if i was the prosecutor i
would have thrown my shoe at him
like what was that well here's the thing
the prosecution actually a lot of people
don't know this everyone's micked up
they'll have lav mics
and we there was a hot mic we have the
exclusive uh right here of the audio of
the prosecution at that key moment uh
what he was saying
now you had mentioned that you believe
that he was re-racking i think you i
don't know much about okay come on gage
this is not a hard one just do it like
we rehearsed
the ball is yours you just gotta sail it
past pointed your gun at him
advanced on him with your gun now your
hands down pointed at him
that he fired right
correct
me hard oh
[ __ ] me hard
that's
telling rough day yeah yeah he sounds
less goofy in that i don't know he's
putting on appearances
didn't work okay
yesterday here's the witness
it looks like my bicep being vaporized
vaporized
dumb i don't even know how to just want
to be a doctor hebert what's up my bicep
being vaporized yes
yeah yes it is by the way to be clear
we're laughing at the choice of words
yeah not harm oh yeah no no
someone who is trying to shoot someone
on his back and his bicep being
vaporized no that's not funny at all
in no way i just think the choice of
words of vaporized is humorous yes yes
not the situation not at all never
not mentioned bicycle you know the the
pedophiles uh who spent time in prison
that's where their ass gets eviscerated
ah this is just yeah big words that
one's gone
that looks like my anus has been
destroyed yes yeah it looks like my
rectal fissure has been decimated yes
you could uh drive a truck through it
yeah that is my anus being titanic
it belongs in branson it belongs in
branson
right the half thing the whole damn near
killed him all right can you eat the
cake gotta lick the frosting too so
you don't know what i'm saying
what do you mean here's here's the
here's the witness nathan de bruyne who
i believe is in i say this on the
spectrum photographer yeah who uh
just
was and by the way just so you know
prosecution i'm going to give you some
advice here and i shouldn't be doing
this no uh if you get someone on the
stand who might be on the spectrum don't
immediately put them on on the defensive
and make them uncomfortable
go back and watch this day this is yeah
uh yes whatever the tenth today so it's
on the ninth go back and watch how the
defense handles this person versus how
the prosecution handles this person he's
regardless of where his uh you know his
motivations lie or his political
leanings lie the truth is you can see
one person tried to make him comfortable
and one person tried to attack him and
as someone who's worked with people with
special needs that's it's never a good
idea yeah ever
but i guess the prosecution didn't know
so i want you to watch here uh the
prosecution who actually by the way is
brian stelter fast forward 30 years
interview nathan de bruin and watch the
case come apart and we asked if you knew
anything beyond that statement correct
we didn't ask you to change it
you yes you did
so you certainly have to change it to
identify mr zaminski yes how did the
meeting end
what do you mean how the meeting how did
our meeting end our meeting over with my
attorney you said literally we would
retype the statement that you checked
november 11
he didn't say re-type it but he
said do i want to add anything to that
and to
how i interpret that that's pretty much
altering my statement and
i felt uneasy about that did you go and
give an interview to a
uh
a gossip site that is a biased against
uh what his site represents
first of all he came to me i didn't go
to him let's make that get it right
don't understand that he has a bias in
this case
i
i don't know i don't know him personally
it was
besides the
uneasy feeling i had it was pretty
pretty much like a normal meeting
so when we ask you if there's anything
to add or beyond your statement change
that made you feel uneasy yes
i first of all it was like i said when i
first walked into the police station i
walked through a police station that
didn't even have a door didn't have no
glass attached there was glass on the
ground completely all shattered on the
ground i have photos don't worry
um shattered all over the ground it was
a very you guys had me waiting
constantly your thing was an hour and a
half long
don't know what right i don't know how
long it was and they were in the room
within five minutes of you walking in
the
i don't know
so the fact there was no window
made it so you could not give an
accurate statement i'm not saying that i
said it
it gave me anxiety
yeah so make sure you say what i'm
saying
they are incapable of lying you can't do
that this should say what i'm saying so
you said because there was a broken
window you couldn't get what he was
trying to say is because they so here
let's keep this in mind no my friend
matt has asperger's though it's like
they don't lie they don't they're not
lie very direct like you can't sit there
and try to get like throw them through a
loop like that you feel like dude i look
like i gained weight you mean aside from
the 50 pounds yeah
they'll just say how they feel and
you're like wow that that just cut like
a knife yeah
it was so awesome so this keep in mind
too uh gage the guy with the gauge he
failed to let the officers know even
though he gave a statement with all
kinds of details that he had a gun yeah
that he had a 40 cal glock 27 i believe
fourth generation if i'm going by rote
here forgot that and he may have told
some officers that he dropped and lost
his gun and these guys here are trying
to ask him they're trying to say so uh
you left out of your statement that uh
gage grabbed the gun why didn't you
remember that he's trying to say because
i'm going into basically a destroyed
police department yeah there are still
people out there protesters i'm feeling
uncomfortable about it right
and not to mention you guys asked me to
rewrite the statement you made me sit
there and wait as a power move you asked
me to alter the statement i was anxious
and the details that he forgot were not
key to the case unlike the guy gage
who's suing the city for 10 million
dollars by the way so he needs kyle to
be guilty saying uh oh it slipped my
mind that uh
i had a gun in my hand and it happened
to be aimed at cal written house didn't
you remember what color shirt kyle was
wearing
you know but you know no recollection of
having a locked and loaded 40 cal in
your hand ah you know must have slept
well
kyle's trying to not go to prison right
you're trying to get 10 million dollars
i wonder who we should believe in this
situation yeah
also was he the one who beat his
girlfriend
it's so hard to track so many people
there's criminals everywhere in this one
by the way there's a lot of people
wondering why we're not covering kyle
right now do you want to do you want to
cover it now do you want to try to do it
tomorrow we can push the segment what do
we want to do you guys let us know we
can because i see a whole segment on
secession and and why should we throw it
to the likes we could we could well all
right let's throw okay
you guys want but we also have the guest
ed der that's true so we would we would
have about 30 minutes to cover kyle's
testimony what do you guys think here
you guys let us know okay if there's a
last time i understand if there's 10 if
there's 10 000 likes we're at 17 right
now no an additional 10 000 likes right
now in the next what should i say three
minutes
three minutes three minutes ten thousand
likes we'll cover kyle written house
twenty minutes and thirty three seconds
yeah that's fine what why i don't know
that sounds like you're making me
confused
be nice to dave we just went over this
be nice we got a clock going
what he he might say just rumbling into
the mic oh just oh
i thought you were saying because he was
autistic can't steam that well i'm not
i am not that smart my wife told me she
thinks i'm on the spectrum by the way i
think you're on the spectrum i think
she's accurate i think you should [ __ ]
yourself how about that
i don't even i don't know i mean maybe i
am i'm incapable of holding it in you're
short
you had a weird tooth for nine years
stop it oh my gosh why would he say
stuff like that please nobody subpoenaed
me i don't even mean it as a negative no
because i don't know what they think it
could be
you want to bring up the trial while
we're waiting for the three minutes no
because then yeah we can't give it to
him
this is what i was planning on talking
about secession in america and actually
who gets to keep america as a country
versus america number two uh and that's
something we can talk about that
tomorrow but uh yeah you know i've got
this thing laid out i know i mean it
they would we would have to see the
likes and if we need to and if we see
the likes by the way people in the
control room as we're flying blind you
guys will we'll have to live fact check
it and you guys have to get us the info
because i want to make sure that we
don't get it wrong because because
youtube is not yeah give us any grace if
in real time we go i don't think that's
right right and we're slightly incorrect
even if cnn uploads a blatantly false
video or segment three days later when
they should have been able to do their
due diligence by the way how did cnn and
all these other news outlets
and left-leaning uh shows on youtube how
did they not know that kyle rittenhouse
was chased by rosenbaum remember i came
in one day token and i said wait hold on
a second because i'm always watching
liberal news sources yeah they're saying
wrote they're saying that kyle written
has chased rose
is there footage that i haven't seen
because i've watched about three hours
of footage
i said is there is there is there
anything like i couldn't even see how it
could be interpreted that way it turns
out they just can't be bothered to do
their job no that's not well they're
barely using the trial footage that's
what's so creepy about it i know are we
are we there what do we have almost we
got one thousand to go one thousand to
go make it right i guess
i i just want to tell you gross quits
the one of the one of the best quotes
from the trial name is mr gage's mr
bicep they call me mr gage's this is a
direct quote from him he said in that
moment i was trying to preserve my own
life but doing so this is the best part
but doing so while taking the life of
another is not something i am capable of
or comfortable with doing and i'm like
then why do you point the gun at his
head
capable of taking his life to defend
yours what are you doing with the water
can someone tell me is he the one who
put a knife to his brother's throat or
is he the one who beat his girlfriend so
i guess well he's capable of threatening
with weapons but he's not really going
to use it right he's not right oh okay
so he's just going to point it at him
and say don't please
would you rather mansplain well yeah
exactly is there a song about this
all right well if you point a gun at
somebody they're not going to know your
moral background in fact they're
probably going to think it's not very
immoral no i said look i if if if i knew
you know rosen if okay and just so you
know language warning we're about to go
to kyle written house if i were written
house my defense on the stand would be
uh so why did you shoot him i would say
in language i would say well your honor
i thought he was trying to [ __ ] me
what would you do
what what do you mean well i know that
he had this is fact some references
about liverpool.com i know that he had
at least anally raped one minor
nine-year-old and uh molested at least
four others if not raped them and he was
running towards me a minor yelling [ __ ]
you and i thought i thought he was going
to [ __ ] me
that simple they go case dismissed i
thought he was gonna [ __ ] you too yeah
let's get cookie yeah i would have
assumed i've had him in my court he
wants to have sex with everything that's
nutty you know honestly
who's up for an orange julius all right
let's go let's go to the mall yeah let's
see kyle right now what are you saying
here
all right 3 15 through three was there
any discussion regarding car source at
that time yes what um nick smith once we
picked him up we drove he wanted to go
to a bank to withdraw money the bank was
closed and then he was like hey would
you guys like to come with me and help
watch over the car sources under fire
there's no fires or anything
and dominic said yes i i agreed i said
okay
and then i said here nick i don't i
don't really need my bulletproof vest
i'm going to be helping people with
first aid so i gave him my bulletproof
vest and by you giving him he looks like
that kid what's the name of that actor
the uh the neighbor in uh santa clarita
diet someone bring it up we'll bring it
up later the the neighbor kid in santa
clarita diet airport yes
it was issued to me by the grace lake
police department
you didn't purchase it no i did not
and after you gave him your bulletproof
vest where to go
we went back to nick smith's house where
we parked dominic black's car
and then what did you do
we walked from mr smith's house
once we parked at
nick smith's house we walked from nick
smith's house
to the car source
one
cutting through the ruther central
backside parking lot because nick smith
lives on the same street of you don't
have to say we're next okay
he lives in the walking dead so nervous
he looks like he looks like 15. and so
you go to car source one yes and that's
the bird belt one
uh no car source 2 my bad across the
street okay
and at car source 2
that's where you spent most of the
evening
yes
when you first got to car source 2 the
one at 59th and sheridan what happened
um the owners were there sam sal and his
father and i believe i i think it was
his uncle there also he was driving a
van of some sort
oh no he wasn't driving it with
rosenbaum wasn't it
you think this is a
hey do you think this is a mistake
putting him on stand i don't think they
need to do it look how nervous he looks
when his own guy's asking him questions
i don't know what's going to happen but
i don't think they need to do it no i
think right now is just let the
prosecution shoot themselves on the
floor yeah well he's
probably nervous 24 7 regardless i know
well that's why you don't put him on the
stand right then he can't be
cross-examined i mean once you're chased
by a pedophile you're nervous for life
well that's true you know
i'd probably be uh you know i'd be
sweating bullets yeah
or shooting them yep through a bicep
not that that would be funny no no you
don't like a vaporizer yeah you don't
know you want a vapor right you want to
we got out set to stun dave not paper we
hung around for you want to use a proton
pack some people showed up
i now know who they are but at the time
i didn't
[Music]
now if i'm not mistaken can someone
correct me here i want to make sure i'm
right the prosecution
rested their case yesterday yes so is
this the defense so this is the defense
calling this is the so that's
interesting by the way everyone out
there watching this isn't it interesting
to note that the prosecution
never had any interest they can't call i
know they can't call but they didn't
have any interest yeah and really they
actually if you listen to what they were
talking about
they
spoke about everything really other than
kyle writtenhouse yeah
they spoke about the people and their
parents and they didn't say what he was
doing that day they really tried to
avoid it so it'll be interesting to see
the cross-examination here because i
think they i wouldn't be surprised that
the prosecution
tries to whiz past this one because i
don't think it'll help them i don't
think they're going to spend a lot of
time with kyle
i think they're going to try to make him
look bad hey look there's a hair hat oh
my god look at that guy
oh and it's dying looks like happy
gilmore's boss oh no oh no
you can count on me waiting for you in
the parking lot
doesn't it
shooters
this is me this has a nail in his head
do you have fu manchu goatee dye to
match my wig
sir we don't do color matching here go
to the ace hardware my driver's license
is just for men
you
did not know the owner of carson's
previously i did not
was
he
being nice to you guys was he happy you
were there was he mad at you for being
there describe it
he was happy we were there okay
i don't think he looks like a killer
which is i think why they put him up
here that's probably why he looks very
he looks
young he looks did you guys bring up a
picture of that actor from the santa
clarita diet that kid permission
i'm just trying to see if that's the
right one but the control room should
send it to you token alan you can't be
doing that right google instant come on
guys send it to him don't make him have
to google this right now the googly
moogly's 10 minutes before this
photograph was taken did you know any of
them i did not have you ever spoken to
any of them no
and
when you were there
what was the idea was there a plan what
was going to happen
yes the plan was to i i went down there
to provide first aid i also i i brought
my
um orange no not him first aid kit uh
no the neighbor with freckles
that was hard the moments passed
with first aid stuff got by my feet to
provide first date the
orange box by your feet you refer to as
a pelican box yes did you have that
before the 25th yes was it stock yes
with things that you had bought and
brought yes
and
do you go
with that every day or is that because
of the situation it was in the trunk of
my car okay
and the fanny pack what's the situation
with that it was my work bag um i'm
messing with them on style choices are
we lifeguard
no i know i'm just playing like why are
you gonna bring up the fanny pack bro
yeah by the way just so you know fanny
pack is like uh uh
uh what are the things called uh for
flies
well the things that attract flies oh
the the the the zapper yeah yeah fanny
packs are like fly zappers for
pedophiles just so you know
it's like a big target it's freaking
catnip for pedophiles right above your
booty
it's like a best friend's heart locket
i don't like you saying the word booty
it just throws me off i don't like it
either sorry yeah yeah unless it's
referring to pirate treasure yeah
or popcorn in which case we all partake
well who doesn't
my friends and then ryan ball said hey
so the people
a group of people
was gonna stay at car source three and
the people depicted how many car sources
are there a lot are these just different
lots or are there a bunch of car sale
used car lots like car source one car
source two they just have like a bidding
they just have a war with signs like all
right i'm car source screw you i'm car
source i'll be car source one i'm taking
it carson and then three comes in he's
like ah now you both this is the real
car source i knew i should have
trademarked the name
it's like raised pizza in new york they
all claim to be the original no they're
not
they were not
they left you guys there yes i i believe
next weird little city though
throughout the night
yeah why why is that tape
what do you have four car you got one
block basically
got four cars listen there's you can't
have too many crappy car lots in one
time you know how happy the owner
probably secretly was they burned it he
was like oh finally i'm going to make
money off this insurance
hey guys come over here and burn this
this jerk slot
yeah we'll protect it for you i'm good
yeah fine that's okay no no really we
can put no no
you don't you don't need to put yourself
up no it's no problem you go it's fine
why does the whole lot smell like
gasoline yeah in other cars no no no
what are you talking about i don't smell
anything hey why are you usually you
want you should talk mr fanny pack
i didn't personally but the people that
were my lawyer agreed not to bring up
the fanny pack
and then screwed me on the stand see
them but that's how they got you should
be disbarred sir
where were you predominantly a car
source too
i was in front of the car source too
as well or the second one
which two during the night were you at
oliver would you say you're
the whole time omni prison
no not the whole time
not just sometimes you would leave car
source too what were you doing
when
when i left i was shooting pedophiles
with ryan bulge and we would go out
turns out ask if anybody needed any
first aid assistance and we would see if
there were any fires and we would put
them out by the way he's on camera
offering first aid and putting out
fights
where i put one out at the church um
over theirs
um
there was the demolishing they were
breaking some stuff down but right here
i believe there was another building
with an alleyway it was either right
here right here i don't remember don't
get too specific kyle yeah fully just i
put in a fire by
where they were trying to set the
building and church on fire and me and
mr bulge and i believe somebody else was
with us don't worry about that we went
to go put that fire out did you put it
off we did
then he's on camera with the fire
extinguisher by the way maybe you guys
can bring that up in the control yeah so
we can fact check this central high
school on fire the front doors
and we were walking north down sheridan
road
to go put the fire out um and then
somebody else put the fire out before we
got to root their center front is that
right here in civic park
no sorry that's my mistake
you're walking north on sheridan it's
the it's the side of the building on
sheridan road towards the left when
you're walking north
he makes painful gilbert godfrey faces
yeah
no i was at car shores four
that's when the pedophile
you saw the hd he was getting close
how did you know he was a pedophile
there you go him with the fire
extinguisher how do you know he was a
pedophile mr written house wow
when a bald man with a mental hospital
plastic bag is walking down an alleyway
with a raging erection
he's not collecting for the red cross
too early for that i missed bernie
i miss bernie
sanders by the way i think do you think
again a mistake by this attorney don't
ask him these detailed questions let
kyle answer i'm hoping i'm hoping
they're laying a trap i do too but i'm
like do you see what he's doing oh no
it's actually this side and maybe this
and oh it's it's like trouble you still
want to have a duran or should we be
just continuing with his trial what's
the what's the word it could go for like
two hours yeah we could probably do
during then come back
okay and get it as long as i just don't
want to make this show super complicated
right right so
if you get you guys let me know what you
think is best here i want to because i
can't see what people are talking about
he he just said rosenbaum threatened to
kill him twice oh he didn't he was just
mad about something me and me and mr
bulch were asking people if they needed
medical help and then he screamed if so
their sounds out ah they do it i think
it's because he was swearing yeah yeah
he said the f word which is also a real
problem
don't sanitize it yeah don't sanitize it
look let me just say one thing really
quickly this matters because they're
gonna bleep it out okay when
there's when they're trying to say a
white supremacist went down to kenosha
and you guys don't allow the truth to be
spoken people won't know that there was
only one person screaming the n word at
the top of his lungs and it was the
child rapist
another guy he's he was screaming
he said
n-bomb
yeah yeah they're saying it's i'll kill
you n-word
i hope he doesn't say yeah jacoby said
he doesn't say that well someone else
actually said the n-word yeah
did they yeah
yeah yeah you have to in court so you
just you got these people have to be
clear about it for crying out loud do
you think someone's reporting that a
pedophile is young end where it makes
them racist well here's let's be adults
now well here's what would happen kyle
rittenhouse on the stand repeatedly uses
the n-word that's the headline from our
you know trusty friends that's what i
mean like it it's it can be damning i
believe it's just for the sake of media
fire
i don't know i don't think he i don't
think you don't matter but then i saw
him with you
he was either helping starter or he was
like throwing stuff on it i don't know
which one he was doing where did you
originally
so he he said that rosenbaum said i'm
going to cut your effing heart out and
kill you edward wow wow
and the saint james and that's uh
probably the least appropriate use of
the n-word ever directed at that kid oh
right exactly the backish corner what it
what i remember and
did you see how it got well it's good
that he's not just a pedophile he's also
extremely violent and racist yeah yeah
and racist i i
it was several all right
apparently confused because kyle's not
you know yeah i bet you kyle's reaction
was just like he's like i'm going to
kill you inward and cowardice
is there is there somebody going to go
down there must have been a
well-attended funeral
the car source for a great human being
you referred to mr zaminski before
august 25th of 2020 had you ever met mr
zaminski i have not did you ever know no
kids allowed though
shane
not allowed within 100 yards of the
casket
or at least three feet
go say goodbye to your uncle but you got
to do it from the parking lot
it was going to be a closed casket but
they they couldn't manage it because the
last thing you saw was a miner so um
they couldn't close the lid yeah blue
mask and
what was on because he has an erection
it was odd he
he
cremated before he died
now
did you provide medical help
to anyone i did describe a couple of
those all on film
um
the first time i provided medical help
to someone was
um
this lady i i think she sprained her
ankle or twisted it i i don't know
exactly i'm not an expert on x-rays or i
wouldn't know
um don't say stuff like that she hurt
her ankle and she was being carried by
two gentlemen it was more of a cankle
hey do you need help
and
she said yes and i said okay let's go
into the car source where i was helping
people
and i wrapped her ankle and then she
went on her way and i said i told her i
let her know there was a hospital
if you go
i want to say southbound sheridan across
the street from car source 3. i let her
know that the hospital was over there
and she should go get it let her know to
go past four burning buildings and make
a left at the burning church
somebody threw a chemical if you get to
the pedophile you've gone too far yeah
chemical doctor i heard
the
i'm gonna cut your hearts out for mr
rosemont i don't know who threw it but
somebody threw a chemical bomb
and
ryan balch had some effects of it so i
helped mr bulge with being able to can
they find the control yesterday the
prosecution actually said something like
so aside from the uh bricks
and
chemical uh bombs you weren't hurt aside
yeah the gas bombs yeah that's what he
just was talking about but the
prosecutors aside from a few castles i
mean
boys will be boys
so other than the punches he never hit
you that's right oh yes okay the first
time a big so after he hit you so many
times your eyes closed uh you couldn't
see any who was hitting you could you
why did you think he was gonna kill you
because he said i'm going to [ __ ]
kill you inward about five times but
aside from that other than that i felt
he was yelling it at me because it was
directed at me yeah yeah yeah he didn't
have any weapons well he had a chance i
was the first confused thought it
couldn't be me because he referred to me
as the n-word but i quickly noticed that
he referred to everybody as the n-word
yeah so i just went by his line of
vision which was
tractor b he also looked so crazy that
every black person around just let him
say it yes
you and mr mcginnis
you know how crazy you have to look to
get away with that yeah
i get done with my interview with you
either crazy autistic or eastern block
yeah that's black people yeah you say
the n word like hey man you're like what
what do you do
what team is he on i i have no idea
we're
we're just hoping it goes home i wrestle
better for toilet paper you're not going
to intimidate me with jive talk no
and you know
20 million dollars for what i did to
bear it was in danger
i gave him fentanyl yes i wear this hat
now
yes like i recommend
all right silence are we having a duran
or no
i believe so okay yeah
i believe we stay just to the right uh
going south on sheridan road and
eventually you cross sheridan road
eventually and were the bearcats there
yet
uh no beer cats
the football team the hockey
street
okay had they set up a line to stop
people that you were aware of
not that i was aware of um i just know
they were parked right there people were
throwing rocks at them did anybody tell
you not to cross that line you wouldn't
be able to go back not until later in
the evening okay you cross that line and
where do you go
we continue straight
uh
straight in a southerly direction down
sheridan road okay where you going might
be some value to this though uh in the
sense that think about it they're
establishing a pattern and
this is something too where the
prosecution is really screwed up and i
know i'm not going to try and interrupt
too much here because i'm learning as
all of you are but um the prosecution
screwed up by asking questions i didn't
know the answer to that's the first rule
of lawyering whereas right now obviously
since this is the defense's witness
they're asking questions i know the
answer to and i'm pretty sure they know
as we know there's videographic or
photographic evidence for all of us it's
establishing a pattern of him being
there cleaning up graffiti offering uh
you know medical assistance putting out
fires yeah that's important because this
whole idea of this little kid was out
there looking for a fight here's my one
thing though we don't even need to go go
down this rabbit show when people say oh
what was what was he doing there why did
he go down he was if he's going down
there he's looking for trouble hey you
know what okay cal right now can answer
what he was doing there uh you first
what were you looking for how many
burned down bill properties no oh so the
fire so you're saying no one was hurt no
it's that the fires were raging so they
could be seen from a satellite for
crying out loud there are only a few
man-made items you can see from
satellite orbit the great wall of china
and kenosha that night
that's true but i'm carrying but of
course people were hurt the media
doesn't care you're talking about
thousands of arrests you're talking
about thousands of casualties throughout
these rights no casualty also includes
injuries just clear so let's just be
when they say what was he doing there
what were the people you're defending
doing there also they happen to be
pedophiles and uh wife beaters sorry not
wife beaters
broad beaters because they wouldn't have
the honor of putting a ring on it
someone called beyonce well they acted
like he went down there in a make
america great again hat and just started
picking people off right yeah and that's
not and honestly i didn't know if that
wasn't the case from all the coverage
that i saw and watching this
it's like
he has every right to be there as
everybody else has a right to be there
right
and he has a right i wouldn't have
rushed down there if i was his age
because i wouldn't have cared and i like
we've said before if it was my kid i'd
be like what is wrong with you like i'm
not saying that he should have joked
because you want to protect your kids
but yeah it's certainly honorable when
you look at what he was doing what is
the day yeah his intentions were to help
yeah
i think that's important yeah as i did
that i received a phone call from
dominic black hey look let me back
i was able to get back the car source
number two no i did not describe that
as i was trying to get back um
the police
stopped me well it didn't stop me they
told me i believe they said something
along the lines of
to not go down there and i was telling
them hey i i need to go down there
that's where i'm at that business i
don't remember exactly how that
conversation went but
they wouldn't let me go back to carsor
slot number two
so you weren't able to get back to car
source too i was not did you
disobey the police's order no and
you're alone you're stuck on the other
side of the police line from the car
source to where do you go
i go to where there's other people at
the gas station
protecting the gas station
and
i i go there because i believe that's
the safest place to go because there's
other people there well that was a it
was a misjudgment yes it was
like i thought the gas station was the
safest place until the pedophile lit a
dumpster on fire and pushed it towards
the gas pumps then i realized i made a
horrible mistake
right there the all three we can have
ed duran today or we'd have to have him
on next week okay well you guys let me
know uh let let me know in the comment
section if you want to continue covering
the trailer do you want ed durr the new
jersey
uh truck driver who put it in the chat
yeah put in the chat on my club chat
dominic black calls me and he says kyle
i need you to get down to the car source
lot number three
the cars are being bashed in they're
setting all the cars on fire i need you
to go and put the fires out okay
and
did you do anything as a result of that
phone call
i did what
at the ultimate gas station i asked
i i don't know who he is but i asked an
individual if he could come with me and
if i could have a fire extinguisher to
put out the fires
were both of those requests
satisfied one of them were what
i was given a fire extinguisher but he
he said he can't come with me and he
said he believes there's already people
down there all right look let me just
say one thing here too this is pretty
think about this there's videographic
evidence we just showed you that he
asked for a fire extinguisher so on
camera he was providing medical
assistance and and no side is perfect in
this
this kid's about as close to a to a damn
hero as far as going down there trying
to help the community as you get before
we even talk about the shootings but
he's on camera
asking for a fire extinguisher he's on
camera putting out fires he's on camera
delivering medical assistance he's not a
qualified paramedic okay you weren't
there you didn't help shut up
he's down there cleaning up graffiti
this this is all
on video hours of cal written house
before the shootings
contrast that with
rosenbaum is not only not on camera
providing assistance or getting a fire
extinguisher putting out fires he's on
camera taking part in arson and
screaming that he's going to kill people
and repeatedly using the most racially
charged epithets you can the other guys
who we're talking about are on camera
screaming get his ass get his ass get
him or hitting him with a skateboard let
me ask you this is there any footage of
kyle just saying something
like get his ass because i've only seen
him say so we don't even need to get to
bombs we don't even need to get to
lighting dumpsters on fire and pushing
them towards gas pumps how about just
kyle rittenhouse is not only on camera
with a fire extinguisher putting out
fires and helping people he's not on
camera before we get to the child rape
he's not even on camera instigating
anything screaming get his ass get him
where is everyone
everyone that he shot was in addition to
their lengthy lengthy criminal records
isn't that kind of it's kind of relevant
right it's kind of relevant it's a
different it's a different timeline up
to these events
yeah
well and i think i don't know what we're
seeing in the chat yet but uh i i think
it might be best to to bump the guest to
next week because i think this is no no
we've oh never mind we have it never
mind we have ed dirk we're good all
right we have apologize all right really
quickly folks we are going to uh do we
have a stinger here yes all right we
have our guest he is the uh well now
he's actually uh
in new jersey do you guys have him yes i
just want to make sure that i have them
hold on one second let me make sure that
i get uh give it my confirmation
you're looking token out and you look
very confused
just confirming that he can hear us
we'll hold one
oh they're just testing audio make sure
you're getting them all squared well
then bring up kyle right now so we're
waiting okay out of that situation and
go back north shore why is the guy
with no bicep not being charged
that's what i wonder what yeah it's
attempted murder yes it could be after
did you get it should be it could be
after the suit yeah you know
at least give him a jesse i don't know i
don't know how much he cost the city
yeah in trying to charge uh what was it
was a ten million dollar civil suit
against the city
against against the city against the
city
send him the bill at least did he pay
two kenyans to chase down written
i'm not sure how much a round of 223
costs but kyle needs to be reimbursed i
was cornered from in front of me with
mr zaminski
and there were
old dirk
there were
three
people right there
see that's really
[Music]
[Applause]
you'll remember where you were when you
saw this time for our break anyway
you can just relax for a minute sir uh
we're gonna take a break uh about uh ten
minutes all right please don't talk
about the case during all of you just
right now first off that just changed
the case you will remember where you
were when you watched it i'm glad that i
was there to share that with you
gage didn't
none of the other witnesses brought
forward did
look the kid's not a professional actor
and i don't think he that's that's an
academy award performance if he is
that's a kid who was overcome with
emotion
and again you're talking about a kid who
was there to put out fire to provide
medical assistance who was there because
he saw a town on fire and generally
feels bad that he hurt somebody who was
trying to kill him yeah yeah
you know who doesn't feel that way the
ear gauge guy who didn't care at all who
sat there with dead eyes like it was no
problem well not only that but you know
who doesn't feel that way the person who
runs up and points a gun at somebody who
is not violent toward them the person
who puts on a mask and runs out behind a
car screaming [ __ ] you and i'll kill you
when they weren't aggressive towards
them and corners them or attacks people
smaller and weaker that are turned
around right
god my heart breaks for that kid yeah
but you know what that's
that's real maybe that's why they put
him on the stand yeah because i knew you
know what this trial needs a little bit
of authenticity all of a sudden when the
veil of
pomp and circumstance is lifted
and you just see this is
a kid
who
had to make some tough decisions
who ultimately is gonna have to live
with this for the rest of his life
and that's why when people say that's
why think of how evil it is for a second
think of this for a second that kid is
there crying
right and all of you right now we all
feel
hopefully unless you're a sociopath like
rosenbomber like a gage uh sorry i get
it hearsay but unless you're a sociopath
your heart goes out to that kid
even the media is trying to acknowledge
he's not a stone cold killer right but
think about this for a second
the kid was banned from gofundme
posts praising kyle rittenhouse
were removed
from facebook from twitter under their
guidelines of supporting mass shooting
do you know what do we have that clip we
have that clip of uh biden which clip is
it biden weighed in or on this clip r
biden weighed in and i was going to use
this uh before on the uh you know the
secession of states in america biden
weighed in on this case
before the trial even started to be
clear here you go here's the president
of the united states condemning this kid
before no doubt he had watched any
footage
i'm praying the verdict is the right
verdict which is i think it's
overwhelming in my view
just imagine being that kid it's like
okay we know now what happens
we know now and you know with the
benefit of hindsight with the benefit of
all of this footage
uh biden is such an [ __ ] i know he's
such a pity i really can't even pretend
he's not
we know what's going on he doesn't know
not to mention that they were they were
videotaping the jurors
they were caught videotaping the jurors
this week they're trying to dox the
jurors here you know do we have that
clip of them here you go here's the
judge talking about they were caught
trying to pressure
the jurors to try and slant the jury and
you wonder why
people on the right say that the left
hates the united states of america what
they hate due process they hate the
right to self-defense they hate the
right to free speech and he and in this
case
with one simple act of trying to
videotape the jurors and make it public
they're infringing on all of those the
first amendment the second amendment not
to mention due process and a fair trial
here is the judge talking about it
yesterday this morning
at the
pickup was someone there and was video
recording
the jury
which
the officers
approached the person and
required
him to him her i didn't even ask
to um
delete the video
and return the phone to him um i've
instructed that if it happens again
there to take the phone
and bring it here so
so
we just saw kyle written out so i was a
breaking down crying um
it would be one thing you know there was
a time in this country where
uh
let's just say this was a he said versus
pedophile said he said versus wife peter
said he said she said it was but it's
it's not
it's overwhelming
amount of
video
overwhelming amount of evidence
overwhelming amount of eyewitness
testimony including the witnesses who
were brought forward by the prosecution
by the way let's be clear about that
today's the first day the defense has
brought forward
any of their witnesses
let's be really clear about that the
overwhelming amount versus
people who have active criminal records
and were on camera that night trying to
cause him here's the thing what you just
saw boil over
with kyle rittenhouse
is
first and foremost i'm sure overwhelmed
with emotion because he seems to
genuinely feel
i don't i hope he doesn't feel guilty
if i could talk to him i would say don't
don't feel guilty about what you did but
i know he feels bad i know that i've
never been in a situation where i've had
to take a life
and by the way that's also why i think
it's important for people like us to
praise him when people say well you you
just praise him you don't know how hard
it is take a life that's absolutely
right that's why i praise the kid
who went there to help to be clear
who went there to serve his community
who went there to provide medical
assistance i think it's important to
praise the kid i think the kid is
dealing with being overwhelmed with
emotions obviously for i really hope not
guilt
but think of what this kid had to fight
this kid didn't just have to go down
there and fight for his life with which
by the way would be enough of a story
think about it
hit in the head with a skateboard
rocked someone else running up on him
with a gun and managing to get a to
clear malfunction and only shoot him in
the bicep that itself is amazing so not
only did he have to fight people that
night
but after that
he had to fight all of the media
remember the media the story white
supremacist goes down to join militia
none of it was true
had to fight the media
had to fight
the president of the united states in
the court of public opinion
had to fight big tech
gofundme boot it hope he sues the [ __ ]
out of them facebook you can't praise
cal rittenhouse really did you remove
any articles that uh said he was a white
supremacist
hey have all articles about the steele
dossier about russia collusion been
removed has hunter biden laptop stories
have they been reapproved no but no one
could get out and we had to deal with
this accurate stories regarding kyle
written house because they labeled him a
mass shooter so the kid couldn't raise
money
the kid couldn't raise money online in
the most effective way possible with a
legal defense fund at gofundme to fight
not only the trial
the media
the president
big tech
and lest we forget
the fbi
the fbi had footage
that they were sitting on
this entire time
lost it isn't it by the way convenient
they found it i guess yesterday they
found some new hd footage don't know if
that was the fbi or not it's pretty
tough to keep track
what do you think you would do at 17
i know what i would do at 17 if they
said by the way you're gonna the
president come out and give a statement
against you're gonna be removed from
every single major social platform
that's available while the media tars
and feathers you and the fbi is gonna
hold on to footage and not release it
that would completely exonerate you and
really eliminate the need for any sort
of a trial in the first place oh and by
the way you're going to have black lives
matter activists and you're going to
have antifa activists
videographing the jury so that they make
sure that justice is served how they
want and by the way even if you win all
of this and by the way that's a big if
the fbi kind of gunning for certain
americans i don't know how they make
their how they go through the selection
process but even if all of this happens
just so you know people are probably
going gonna ride in the streets and uh
you know people are gonna die
if you're not guilty so just so you know
you'll be responsible for more death
that's why that kid broke down
and anyone and this is worth that point
you know i don't want to be that [ __ ]
i don't want to be that guy who just you
know
this is ridiculous and i hate this and
just emote but you know what
anyone who specifically people who work
at facebook who said we're not going to
allow posts praising kyle renton house
because it's a praising of a mass
shooter [ __ ] you
people at gofundme who removed this
kid's ability to defend himself legally
[ __ ] you people at the fbi who had
footage and never made it available when
they were going through evidence
[ __ ] you and by the way president biden
who said that he hopes justice was swift
and in this case it was very clear and
severe and and weighed in before the
trial even took place and no doubt
because he cannot be bothered just like
reporters to simply reference the the
hours of footage that is out there
former vice president biden [ __ ] you
this kid is deserved he is owed an
apology from
all of you
all of you
and i hope it goes beyond you're seeing
a lot of people right now in the leftist
media
i don't even want to name him so i'm
pretty sure you can guess i talked about
this even last week and all of a sudden
it's making the rounds in the
conservative blogosphere
a lot of people in the left trying to
distance themselves from this now
saying oh well you know what you know
what it seems like there's two sides and
no no no no
if this isn't a
we were wrong not only that we were
wrong and we're sorry
[ __ ]
you
and let's be really clear he's a proxy
for everyone out there right now
you don't think this can happen to you
this is about your right to self-defense
if this kid doesn't have the right to
defend himself if the kid going down to
kenosha wisconsin where he was a
lifeguard we just found out was given a
flak jacket by the great lakes police
department if this kid who's going down
who's on camera cleaning off graffiti
providing medical assistance putting out
fires and is chased down by a serial
child rapist yelling that he's going to
kill him and then saying [ __ ] you and
then having someone else approach not
approach him storm up on him hit him in
the head with a skateboard and his buddy
come up and try and shoot him in the
head with a 40 cal glock 27 that he
forgot to mention to the police officer
i guess stelter didn't do enough digging
to find out if that was the case could
look at photos in front of him it is it
is we are at a point here
if they can make it
stick and say this kid doesn't have the
right to defend himself none of you what
you you think you have a shot in hell
being carjacked
hey they call them a white supremacist
what if you're in detroit you're being
carjacked by a black guy and there's no
footage and you're a white guy
think you're gonna have the right to
self defense
what if you shoot someone who happens to
be the wrong race and you're the wrong
race
they tried to build this guy as a white
supremacist anyway he shot a guy
practically mid inward
if kyle written house doesn't have the
right to defend himself there can be
this pile on gofundme facebook twitter
youtube the president the fbi
of course they can do it to you
and you know what none of that really
where's the empathy when the left talks
about empathy we're the side that cares
well let me ask you this okay
what would you rather have happened
we rarely stayed home okay but he didn't
i would rather the looters and riders
stay home i'd rather the people who
knock over walgreens and cvs's and
7-elevens in san francisco as long as
it's under 998 dollars i'd rather they
stay home but here we are he didn't stay
home didn't go to steal didn't go to
burn didn't go to loot went down to
clean [ __ ] up so okay i get it you'd
rather he stay home but he didn't it's
his right
what would you rather have happen
he didn't shoot did serial child rape
his pedophile was mentally unstable
threatening to kill him
you'd rather he didn't shoot
mr gage ears
who's within point-blank range and a
glock at his head
genuine question hey former vice
president biden
it's pretty clear
if it's clear you should be able to
articulate yourself i know it's a lot to
ask
would you rather happen
there really isn't a door number three
is there
when the kid is running away
from a pedophile who's chasing him and
only turns around when he hears a
gunshot and the guy is screaming
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
to shoot the [ __ ] who by the way burn
marks on the pedophile's hand because he
was grabbing his gun
there really is no door number three is
there
he didn't ask for that did he
he didn't ask for that
what would you rather have happened
what would you rather happen rachel
meadow would rather happen brian stelter
what would you rather happen young turks
what would you have rather happened all
of cnn what would you have rather
happened and let's say you grant that
okay you granted all right grabbing for
his gun screaming he was cornered okay
shot him didn't have to shoot anybody
else after that running away
all this i don't even bring up the video
right now because everyone has to admit
now that it's correct after that running
away the guy who pulled a gun on him
later mr gage ears saying hey hey hey
hey hey what are you doing i'm going to
the police
didn't run in an alleyway
didn't run out
didn't do any of that ran and made it
clear friendly friendly i'm i'm going to
the police
by the way if one person says i'm going
to the police and the other person says
get his ass
sort of could be an indicator as to
who wants
to actually see justice be served but
you know i digress going to the police
tackled on the ground
one guy who has yet to be identified who
kicked him in the face no idea what
could happen there couldn't possibly be
a glowworm could it
kicked in the
face hit that with a skateboard it's
just a skateboard really
really okay fine just a skateboard well
let's ignore that
you're happy to be knocked on your back
hitting head with a skateboard
note
it
was like i did have a gun
what do you even if you grant the
rosenbob what would you rather happen
you would rather he be tackled to the
ground drop kick in the face hit him
ahead with a skateboard buy someone who
reaches for his gun and the guy comes up
with gage with the glock
and
would rather happen president biden what
would you have rather happened so he
wouldn't be considered a mass shooter
facebook
by the way three companies who decided
to
uh coalesce against him more powerful
than the roman empire keep in mind
google alphabet youtube facebook twitter
what would be required for him to not be
a mass shooter what would be required
for it to be self-defense
did the pedophile have to be in the
process of penetrating him i'm just
sorry to be blunt
this could be anyone
this could be any one of you
and i heart just breaks for the kid when
you just think about that and i'm not
that's this is not hyperbole at all
all of big tech
all of the media
the president
and the fbi
no wonder the kid's crying
all right do we are we're going to move
the guests next week is that what's
happening or is he still there uh i i
don't know if he's still there not mine
okay my call is to do it next week all
right we'll do it next week sorry kyle's
going to come back i didn't want to get
on my soapbox no look no it'll be a
landmark case this is something that we
will look back on and either the right
to self-defense will have lived or died
based on this trial am i the only got
choked up with him crying there no no
for crying out loud i'm trying to not
cry because i'm trying to watch this
with you and i know that if i cry that
makes me a [ __ ] that doesn't make him a
[ __ ]
i'm not going up against the fbi well
not yet i have no idea well do you hear
a drone it could already be yeah a
cessna citation oh shoot dave what's
that a cat gas bomb
uh no dave in the bathroom no i'm just
kidding uh
it's we're all gonna remember where we
were yeah no no i should say that
that would be the oj glove moment if the
media did their job
they want to ignore this at all costs
look think about this for a second
that's a kid who shot three people
including pedophiles and a wife beater
amidst the greatest riot you know
biggest rioting that we've seen in our
country breaking down sobbing in a
murder trial yeah that is that is
basically pornography
for the media for clickbait
let's see if they avoid it well let's
see how they they cover this right
because you know that they're going to
have to mention it somewhat
briefly but let's see how are they going
to mock him what are they going to do
watch how they cover this yeah it's
going to be white supremacist
or shooter from kenosha wisconsin breaks
down thinking about the people he killed
something like that right so framing it
in a way where it makes kyle out to be
the bad guy still yeah
i mean unbelievable
gage went in there smug
is this him is this live they're back
okay
that happened
once i got to that car let mr dirk know
that we're incredibly apologetic
we didn't expect this to happen
obviously yeah kids sobbing i i you know
i hope we're going to make sure we have
you on next week because i'm just trying
to lend him whatever hand i can hear
because we know media is not going to be
covering this i don't know if we should
have a hashtag for what is it is written
house trending or
i don't know we'll look get it out there
yeah that's when i realized the only
place i can run with the people around
me is straight
towards the building of the car source
lot number three
when you saw mr rose mom that's when you
said friendly friendly
when i heard burn inside i don't know
exactly where i was at and the time for
that did mr rosenbaum say anything to
you
um no mr zaminski instructed mr
rosenbaum to get him and kill him that's
what i heard
and
you go running
what's been referred to
the south
west corner of
car source yes and as you're running in
that direction car source four describe
being chased so many of them
as i'm running like rocky movies
direction
mr
rosenbaum throws
i at the time i know it's a bag now but
when he threw it at me
with the light it looked silver and it
looked like the chain
when he threw it at me i
and then
i continued i turn around for
for
about a second while continuing to run
and i point my gun at mr rosenbaum does
that stop him from chasing you
it's just not
they
after you turn around and you had your
hands up kind of in a low ready position
yes and
you see mr rosenbaum coming at you yes
and what do you do then
um
after he throws the bag and he continues
to run he's gaining speed on me a
gunshot is fired from behind me
directly behind me
and i take a few steps and that's when i
turn around
and as i'm turning around mr rosenbaum
is
i would say
from me to where the judge is
of coming at me
with his arms on in front of him
he i remember his hand on the barrel of
my gun
and
why didn't you just keep running and
there were burn marks by the way when i
was over there there were about a
hundred people surrounding
that
that those cars and there was no space
for me to continue to run to which by
the way the fbi news that's on the drone
footage or on the aerial footage didn't
release did you see him lunging at you
what do you do
i shoot him and how many times did you
shoot i believe four
and
after you shot him what did you do
uh the people around
the people around the cars that were
originally there were not there anymore
um they
they moved away and i ran around to
see if i could help mr rhodes and bomb
and when you got to mr roosevelt what
was happening
mr mcginnis was
i he took off his helmet and slammed it
on the ground and took off his shirt and
i don't remember what he said i
wasn't focused on that i was in shock
sort of
let me back up a second
did you know mr mcginnis was even around
i didn't okay and he says something to
you call a reporter for people who don't
know um i pull out my phone and i call
dominic black
and
you call dominic and what do you say i
told them i just shot somebody i had to
shoot him and what do you do then
um
i now know it to be kelly zaminski
joshua zaminski i don't know that other
people were screaming
get his ass get his ass and get him and
get him and get him
and
which is on tape based upon that
here's what's interesting about this
nothing that he is saying usually you
end up with a court case right where the
prosecution calls witnesses and they say
one thing happened then the defense
witnessed to say no actually this
happened
there is nothing in dispute about what
he's saying that's exactly what gauge
gross whatever his name is i can't
pronounce his last name that's exactly
what he said
this is the problem when people say why
are we so divided in america because the
prosecution brought forward people
saying
yeah it was just the guy chasing him
reach for his gun we were yelling get
his ass he ran around and he called his
friend and then he tried to go to the
cops and we hit him with us
they're saying we only reach for his gun
we only hit him with a skateboard i only
took my gun out but i wasn't planning on
shooting him he had no right to defend
himself and the other half of the
country is going he was running at him
screaming he was going to kill him and
you guys were saying get his ass and you
hit him in the head with a skateboard
and he brought it again and tried to
shoot him of course he has right to
defend himself none of it is in dispute
right that's what's that that's why
america is divided just so you know
because one side believes that you have
the right to
protect your life and one side doesn't
particularly depending on the race of
person who does the shooting or who is
shot that's what matters most we have to
see it through the lens of of racial
identity of gender rather than right and
wrong this is what's crazy about this
trial no facts are in dispute no not at
all and like you said earlier they you
don't ask questions you don't know the
answer to the other side of that is they
knew the answers and they thought it
helped them yeah how in the world is
that possible
you know what gage could have done hey
i've not been an [ __ ] well other than
that yeah i just asked him where he's
going he said he's going to the police
he said he's going to the police guys
yeah
yeah on camera while you're yelling get
his ass yeah shoot his ass he's got a
gun you could have helped defuse the
situation right there yeah well they
could have helped use it before uh you
know setting the city ablaze but yeah
well hindsight's 20 20. i don't want a
monday morning riot listen that's
reparations
burning is reparations everyone's an
armchair arsonist these days
[Applause]
well which is a it's it is amazing
really to say that
with the riots that it has anything to
do with racial justice when the people
that were shot were all white yeah and
one of them was screaming the n-word at
the top of his lungs right around black
people
burning down everything is not equality
no no and i'm and you hear something
where it goes what's the voice of the
unheard yeah in the 60s yeah sure you
know but it's like it at this point
people were destroying stuff to destroy
stuff because they were mad
for being locked down in my opinion it
was a reason of course it is he's
getting to the part about anthony okay
sorry and as i block it it goes flying
somewhere off in the distance
and
do you stop then no
what do you do next i keep running down
sheridan road towards the police line
then what happens
i get lightheaded
i almost pass out and i stumble and hit
the ground okay
before you hit the ground how many times
were you struggling
i believe twice okay do you remember
anything about the other one i remember
the first one being a rock i don't
remember who did it but i remember like
the bumpiness of like a concrete rock
hitting me in the back of the head right
now
after being struck before that's enough
reason to shoot someone someone hits me
with a rock you know i have any idea how
many people get killed by hitting being
hit in the head with a bunch of blunt
object oh i've put many in a sock and
taken people out well yeah i usually do
a roll of quarters yeah
or so
there are people around me i don't
recall how many but i remember
moving my rifle in their direction and
they back off besides one person
when you noticed people by you
you said you moved your rifle in their
direction yes did that individual keep
coming
the last person did okay
the people that stopped what did you do
to them nothing okay
and you're saying the last person in
that group
continued to come at you it's actually
an important question everybody asked it
what did you do with that stop it's very
clear that he delineated the last person
um
i i don't know his name i don't think
because there were a lot of [ __ ] in
this equation um you only shot the ones
with his with he was wearing boots i
believe
and
as he's running at me and jumping
i guess those boots are made for dying
in my face i fired two shots at him why
did you shoot him
i thought if
he if i would be knocked out
or
he he would have stopped my face and if
i didn't fire
as a result of being very interesting
mr huber
immediately after i'm kicked in the face
runs up as i'm sitting up to try to get
up and get to the police i'm on my back
and
mr huber
runs up
he as i'm getting up he strikes me in
the neck with his skateboard a second
time mister is my father's name he grabs
my gun and i can feel it away from me
and this i can feel the strap starting
to come off my my body
and what do you do then i fire one shot
and
after you fire striking we now know mr
juber what do you do
i lower my weapon and i see mr gross mom
right with his hands up i imagine the
hell i'm lowering my weapon
i looked down
and then
mr gross scroots
he lunges at me with his pistol pointed
directly at my head
now you heard mr grosswood's testimony
about re-racking yeah this is important
did you re-rack your weapon i did not
could i have the exhibit please he
didn't
i thought he did clear a malfunction
that just so you know
you can admonish me because that was
something that was reported by every
source i thought that he was clearing
him out function in his weapon let's
hear what he has to say
well that's actually important you know
why because if he wasn't
uh if he wasn't like use the term
re-racking or if he wasn't clearing a
malfunction then it's even more of note
that he lowered the gun and moved it
away from crow screws in other words
crushers tried to say i saw him clearing
the gun so i thought he pulled the
trigger and that's what gave me license
to run after him but if he didn't if he
just did this with the gun think about
that that's aiming it in a safe
direction
so i'm very curious to see what happens
here because this may be one of those
key details you guys i do
now when somebody would
as mr grosswood said re-rack
is that this
yes do you call it re-racking
i call it charging charging putting a
light rod into the chamber and to
recharge you have to pull this
all the way back yes
say that's about four inches
no i'm asking you if you agree with that
approximation
mr written come on fat future stilter
don't be a prick
three four inches
and
if the weapon is loaded didn't
if there is already a round in the
chamber
when you re-rack the rifle a live round
would come out
chambering a new round and
into the
chamber now we got to the point
where
mr grow squids is standing in front of
you has his hands up correct and are you
aware these are
at that point i do see a pistol in his
hand is that
the same or different from your first
encounter with mr grossman that is
different
and
he is standing you said
how close to you
what i remember is our feet were
touching what it seemed like okay
and
you do what
my rifle is down
his hands are up
his pistol is in his hand
and then
mr gross scrooge looks at me
and that's when mr gross scrooge
brings his arm down
like this
like his arm is like that with
me on the ground and his pistol is
pointed at me and that's when i shoot
him
how many times do you shoot him once
and
after you shoot mr gross which do you
know where you shot him no
what happens after you shoot him
he's no longer a threat to me
there's only
there's only one person in front of me
and his hands are up i briefly point my
rifle at him
and i get onto one knee getting up and
he backs he backs up with his hands up
and i don't shoot him
did you notice anything right well
listen we're gonna have to go to mugler
here in a little bit but let me just say
something that right there
people may not under so everyone sees
the emotion and obviously that's a huge
moment that we'll all remember where we
were when that happened at least i think
so uh but that might have been the
linchpin for the case because all that
was left today if you look at leftist
reporting was well gross crits shot
because
kyle rittenhouse pulled the trigger it
went click and he cleared to malfunction
and what i want to find out before we
leave today so we'll figure this out on
mug club where did that get started
because we've gotten pretty much
everything else right here but we even
thought that cal rittenhouse had to
clear malfunction as a matter of fact we
included it in our kyle rittenhouse
challenge here which by the way people
thought was far more offensive than the
act of trying to uh face stomp a child
yeah or a teenager let's call him young
adult in the first place could have been
bar mitzvahed um not with a name like
written house it was written berg come
on written steen
stein but gold this could be
uh the pivotal detail there because then
there is no justification for gage mr
gage mr spacers in his ear in case you
had any other reason to question his
soundness of judgment
um and we put in spacers that can never
close up unless through outside of
serious plastic surgery which i will
never be able to afford for obvious
reasons so let's put this guy in the
stand um so
his only justification at that point and
it's still very thin before today was
well he had a clear malfunction
so i thought that he tried to pull the
trigger and already kill me and then i
lunged at him
and that's removed
every single and it still wouldn't even
be enough of an excuse because he's
running up on a kid with a gun but even
then the soup the absolute wax paper
thin it's so the case that is so thin i
can see cuomo's nipple rings through it
is now non-existent yeah and sorry go
ahead and make it because i do want to
get going here to mug club and take some
chat so look guys uh do me a favor
please if you like especially if you
guys like what we do i know it's organic
when this happened here uh hit the like
button comment below if you want more of
this on youtube or we just let the
cameras run and go while something like
this happens every now and then you
can't plan for a historic moment we're
going to continue taking your chat
watching the trial a little bit on mug
club as well as i will not end this show
until we get to the bottom of where that
clearing a malfunction rumor started you
can admonish me
because i got that wrong because
everybody else got it wrong
that's big news today in case you guys
didn't know youtube thank you i'm sure
you're not thrilled with me so you too
considering the fact-checking you did of
kyle rittenhouse not long ago
can piss off
[Music]